Speaker 1: Let's go. Let's go next to Brian in
New Jersey. Brian in Jersey, you're on the air.
Speaker 4: Hello, David. I just wanted
to ask you a question about California,
OK, about the recall candidate, Kevin Frapp, and
how he's running as a Democrat and how centrist
policy I you want to know your opinion that
Speaker 1: I you know, I was interviewed by
Kevin. He's known as Meet Kevin
across the Internet and different
streaming platforms and different things.
And we had a very nice conversation.
He struck me as relatively informed, although
a couple of the questions he asked me were
sort of a little they transmitted a lack of
understanding about some issues, but I have
no idea about his candidacy for governor. I really
don't. And I've been away for a couple of weeks,
so I don't know what is going on. I
don't know if it's a serious candidacy
or a publicity candidacy. I just don't know
Speaker 4: yet because he mentioned in one of
his policies, like a 60 day, he'll remove people,
homeless people from the streets. And it's kind of
a lot of people have been bashing on him saying,
like, how are you going to do that? You know,
like, what is your house going
Speaker 2: to be done?
Speaker 1: Where is you going to put them?
Speaker 4: And that he mentioned something
about like using the National
Guard and setting some places up.
Speaker 1: Oh, boy. Almost like a like an
internment camp or a concentration camp.
Speaker 4: I'm not so sure. I haven't been
keeping up to my. Yeah. And interested.
Speaker 1: Let's make sure we don't make
any claim. We can't definitely back up.
I don't know anything about Kevin. Parathion,
internment camps for homeless, but I just don't
know enough about his candidacy to be honest.
Speaker 4: All right. That was all. Thank you.
Speaker 1: Thank you so
much. I appreciate that call